[Musik]
mit wasser und innereien mit sebastian
liege eine bratwurst die eigentlich
nicht verkauft werden da aber fällt das
den prüfern auf oder kann sebastian
bedenkenlos tricksen
[Musik]
was in die bratwurst darf ist im
deutschen lebensmittelbuch festgelegt in
den leitsätzen von 2060
darin steht welches fleisch zu wurst
verarbeitet werden darf auch der
eiweißanteil im reinen muskelfleisch ist
festgelegt er muss mehr als acht prozent
betragen
so soll sichergestellt werden dass nur
wertvolle zutaten in die wurst kommen
gute regeln aber werden die auch
eingehalten
wie gut sind die kontrollen genau das
will produktentwickler sebastian lege
testen
er stellt die leitsätze für bratwürste
auf den prüfstand um größere ganzen
könnte man ja alles rein macht man was
man möchte kommt eher kleiner so schön
und hier noch ein bisschen und da noch
ein bisschen am ende des tages ist alles
zur em da sebastian liga will heute
selber wurst herstellen mit unerlaubten
zutaten und vielen stritt mitteln
unterstützt metzgermeister krank schwach
heute wird nicht einfach wir wollen so
wenig fleisch wie es geht in die wurst
packen danach wird analysiert im labor
auch wir wollen sehen ob die uns auf die
schliche kommen
das ist spannend dass sie spannen das
weiß ich auch nicht viel was kriegen die
tatsächlich raus erst einmal wollen sie
gestreckte würste machen mit ganz wenig
fleisch und ganz viel wasser
der halbe saal nicht ganz da kann man
eine sehr sehr gute bratwurst mit bach
die beiden verarbeiten schulter fleisch
deckel fett und durch wachsenden bauch
das fleisch ist einwandfrei
[Musik]
wir wollen es aber gen himmel strecken
um eine un- verkehrsfähigen wurst zu
erzeugen aber diese woche musst du ja ja
natürlich
metzgermeister frank stellt nur die
üblichen zutaten zusammen so kuck mal
wenn wir jetzt hier
60 prozent muskelfleisch haben und 40
prozent fett denke ich sind wir ganz gut
dabei
das so die menge für ungefähr 20
würstchen und sich gramm
und da kommt jetzt lecker salz drin dazu
gewürze und frische kräuter einmal durch
den wolf gejagt fertig ist das
handelsübliche brät des metzgermeisters
bis hierher alles so wie es sein soll
wem nützt das als grund drehte das
machen wir zu unseren code auch okay und
das pumpen war gleich mal richtig auf
und jetzt fangen wir schön anzusprechen
eine guten rostbratwurst besteht zu etwa
zehn prozent aus wasser zwei hände voll
eisreichen hier eigentlich hätte ich aus
sebastian lege legt nach drei mal mehr
wasser als erlaubt damit also später
nicht aus der wurst läuft kommt viel
phosphat zum einsatz
[Musik]
und soja protein pulver nicht in einer
bratwurst zu suchen macht sie aber
leicht und luftig frank basars es sieht
aus wie brad ja aber es ist breit
probieren wir mal so nichts giftiges
drin
ich mag dich roth geschmacklich gut die
grundmasse sollte für 20 legale würste
reichen und jetzt wie weit kommt
sebastian läge mit dem gestreckten break
über 40 würste wir haben mal locker
verdoppelt so viel wurst aus so wenig
fleisch diese wüste schicken wir später
in ein staatlich anerkanntes
lebensmittellabor aber sebastian liga
hat noch lange nicht genug
wie viele teilstücke bekommen wir in
eine wurst
du wirst es mir verraten aber es sieht
ja schon grausam aus
in diese wurst kommen innereien und
billige fleischstück niere oder leber
eigentlich tabu
[Musik]
aber das hier so übertreiben und das in
die analyse schicken sie kommen uns auf
die schliche bestimmt also müssen uns
auf die schliche kommen
in deutschland dürfte so etwas nie als
rostbratwurst verkauft werden
genau vor solchen gepanschten waren
sollen uns die staatlichen kontrollen
schützen so ab damit gerade feinen
bratwürsten ist nicht anzusehen aus
wasser hergestellt wurden
gut schaut so aus ich würde auf optische
das war schon ganz schön kuppel lose
hersteller könnten mit solchen tricks
eine menge geld sparen
also das hat nichts mit unserer guten
deutschen gehörig aber fragt man kann ja
mal sehen mit wie wenig fleisch man doch
ne wurst zaubern kann und reich werden
wie gut werden wir vor fleisch panzern
geschützt wir schicken beide chancen in
eine staatlich akkreditierte prüfstelle
der tüv süd e lab gehört zu den laboren
die solche untersuchungen im auftrag von
herstellern und handel durchführen
dürfen
wir beauftragen eine chemische
untersuchung gemäß der leitsätze für
fleisch und fleischerzeugnisse dass
unsere rostbratwürste gepanscht sind
verraten wir nicht denn wir wollen
wissen was taugen die qualitätsvorgaben
und wie gut sind die kontrollen
seit dem gammelfleischskandal von 2005
sind diese fragen besonders wichtig
damals konnten tonnenweise
schlachtabfälle importiert verarbeitet
und weiterverkauft werden
die behörden erkannten den betrug zu
spät in der zwischenzeit landete das
gammelfleisch unter anderem auch im
bratwurst greifen die kontrollen heute
dann müsste uns das labor auf die
schliche kommen
unsere wasser wurst fliegt auf wer zu
wenig fleisch verarbeitet und in eine
kontrolle gerät der wird entdeckt ein
blick ins ergebnis überrascht im labor
wurde die gepanschte wurst sensorisch
geprüft ergebnis in aussehen geruch und
geschmack ist sie laut prüfer produkt
typisch und auch die chemische
untersuchungen ergibt keine
beanstandungen
warum wurden die innereien nicht
entdeckt das labor hat den sogenannten
battle wert ermittelt der gibt den
eiweißanteil im muskelfleisch an
es gilt je mehr eiweiß desto besser ist
die qualität
die leitsätze für eine gute bratwurst
fordern mindestens acht prozent
unsere punch wurst hat man's 13 3
prozent sogar einen herausragenden beste
wert trotz in der 1
das weist darauf hin dass eines der
wesentlichen qualitätsbeurteilung
merkmale nämlich der sogenannte beste
wert nicht ausreicht um die
zusammensetzung und die geeignetheit
einer solchen wurstmasse festzustellen
denn offensichtlich hat der weiß wird
gepasst leber enthält selber endlich
viel muskelfleisch
das heißt das labor hat alles richtig
gemacht
es ist der beste wert selbst der für
eine qualitäts bestimmung nicht
ausreicht dabei können
lebensmittelkontrolleure sehr genau
herausfinden welches fleisch verarbeitet
wurde
zum beispiel durch gewebeuntersuchungen
nur werden solche tests nicht
standardmäßig durchgeführt warum das
ministerium teils schriftlich mit die
amtliche probenahme bei lebensmitteln
und deren untersuchung erfolgt
risikoorientiert das bedeutet es wird
gezielt dort kontrolliert wo verstöße
wahrscheinlich sind bedeutet
untersuchungen auf gewebe werden nicht
regelmäßig durchgeführt sondern nur im
verdachtsfall und der beste wert allein
ist zu ungenau
das stößt bei verbraucherschützern auf
kritik
warum spezifiziert man nicht so
eindeutig dass in den labors auch auf
solche bestandteile wie innere organe
untersucht wird wenn so eine bratwurst
geht die ganz klar aus muskelfleisch und
fett zu bestehen hat
große wurf skandale wurden in den
letzten jahren nicht bekannt weil die
kontrollen aber unzureichend sind bleibt
uns verbrauchern wohl nur zu hoffen dass
kein hersteller punch wo kauft ihr eure
bratwürste am liebsten und worauf achtet
wie er sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über ihr essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die dicksten
zwei clips
[Applaus]